[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Applause]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money
i am rachel cruz at ramsey at
personality and i am hosting at this
hour
of the show and so i'm so excited to be
here with you guys and it's a free call
anywhere in the country at
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so give us a call
and it's so fun because this show we get
to talk about your life we get to talk
about your money we get to talk about
your relationships your career anything
and everything
so give us a call or on social even you
can ask some questions
so one of the exciting things happening
right now at ramsey solutions is dr john
dalone has launched his new book
which is absolutely fantastic
and it's called own your past change
your future so it's available now
for anyone to read and i'm telling you
guys it was um
it's so powerful i finished it actually
in two days
i got a copy of it because it launched
this week which was just
so phenomenal and this whole idea of
saying hey i'm going to take control of
my entire life and part of that is
looking at your past and in my book know
yourself know your money
you know i talk about knowing the money
classrooms you grew up in understanding
how you were raised with money
affects so much of your life and money
is really communicated in two ways it's
communicated verbally but it's also
communicated emotionally and so for some
people growing up you know that they
were raised in a house where money was
talked about but it was normal and it
was good and it was fine uh others they
never heard their parents talk about
money like it was
never a conversation to be had i feel
like
some of those parents kind of lump into
you don't talk about politics you don't
talk about sex you don't talk about
money like you don't those those are
off-limit topics uh and then it's also
communicated emotional you can feel
if it's stressful if you're in an
environment that there's a lot of
anxiety around money but then also
there's the level of just calm and
controlled and having a plan and so all
of that shapes really how you view money
today and people either mirror a lot of
how they saw their parents act with
money
or they do the complete opposite and so
i find that as well and so just kind of
unpacking that past with your finances
is so important but even in his book
he does it about every subject in life
to go through and look at your past and
say hey what influences have now
affected
how i live my life today and so it is a
powerful book you guys again i would
recommend getting it you can buy it
anywhere books are sold but it is it is
so good to go back and say hey here is
what shaped who i am today and here are
the decisions i now get to make going
forward because again it affects every
area of our lives all right we're gonna
go to the phones this hour and sarah
from san francisco is up first hey sarah
welcome to the show
hi rachel i'm a huge fan of yours oh
thank you i'm talking to you i'm so glad
you called how can i help
i want to first even purchase a home in
the future and i want to know if you had
any tips um that could help me yeah
absolutely so where are you at today
financially what's your
what's your situation
financially i have a stable job um i'm
able to save um
some money monthly to put aside but i'm
having
a hard time
managing that money that i put in my
savings i always tend to dip into the
savings
and it hasn't passed a certain level of
um
money over time and so yeah i've had a
hard time with that
what what's causing you to dip into it
just emergencies unplanned things or is
it
more just like spontaneous things you
just want
spontaneous things that i just want
um
i see that money
i guess and i say oh well i want this or
i want that and i'll just dip into the
savings
so for you as a home
i mean it's a it's going to be it's a
goal for you right i mean you are in san
francisco which is like i think the most
expensive real estate in the country so
congratulations sorry about that
um but for you yeah i mean i think
saving a i think saving up for a home
owning real estate as part of your
financial journey
is very important i really am a big
believer of it i love renting especially
if you are
new to an area if you're just starting
out with a new season of life or
something renting is not bad it is not
wrong and some people are like oh it's
just throwing your money away and it's
not i mean it really is giving you a
very stable foundation but eventually
getting to the point where you have home
ownership and you own a home i think
really is important so so for you sarah
i would work on getting completely out
of debt do you have any debt right now
i still have student loans okay yeah and
how much do you have in that
i have ten thousand dollars in my
student loans how much is in your
savings account that you keep dipping in
for for fun stuff
i have around eight thousand dollars
okay
okay so if i were you sarah i really
would i would i would start working the
baby steps and i would say okay i'm
gonna take
seven thousand of that throw it at my
student loan debt get it down to three
thousand i would do anything and
everything to get that three paid off
the rest of the three and then save up
for that emergency fund and that
emergency fund is going to be just for
emergencies which i know as you were
talking it's difficult right because
you're like oh the money is just sitting
there but
putting it aside to know okay if
something happens i have this money and
then from there saving up for a down
payment on a home and again it has to be
something that you have a why for like
you have to be able to look and say gosh
this is why i want to buy a home this is
the area i want to be in
and that does have to be a goal for you
but if you're in a situation that you
don't
necessarily need home ownership right
now or you think you may be changing
um cities or life stages soon and you
don't want to be tied down to a mortgage
you don't have to own a home right now
and again san francisco it's kind of a
tough
um it's a tough spot there but when it
comes to our homes you know it's
it's a it's the probably the largest
financial purchase that we make in our
lifetime i mean it's huge and making
sure that our homes are not a curse but
they are a blessing and so
looking to see what kind of home can i
afford and that's and that's a really
really important thing to look at
because yes while homeownership is
wonderful and great
you don't want it to eat into so much of
your paycheck where it ends up being a
curse so being completely debt-free
having that emergency fund
is going to set you up really well
all right up next is spencer from
chicago hey spencer welcome to the show
hey rachel how are you doing well how
can i help
so i wanted to ask
my wife and i recently inherited about
half a million dollars and we're trying
to figure out whether
the first thing to do would be to pay
off our mortgage with that or to invest
it otherwise
yeah um i'm sorry did it was it a family
member that passed
yes it was yeah was that unexpected or
were you guys yep yeah it was her father
oh i'm so sorry when how long ago was
that
last year in september okay okay i'm so
sorry spencer that's
that's difficult um especially when
things like that are unexpected well
um well he left you guys a really
generous gift um
to be able to use so i'm glad you called
and you know since it was in september i
still think that there's a element um
when people receive an inheritance from
a family member that's passed there's a
level of grief that i really want you to
walk through and actually dr john celine
talks about this a lot um which is so
important that you're not making
financial decisions out of that but
going through that process of really
grieving and then from there yes spencer
if you guys have any debt i would pay it
off i would use some of that to get the
emergency fund in place i would go ahead
and pay off the home
and then from there you guys start
investing 15 of your income into
retirement you can throw some of this at
that retirement
or just mutual funds as well just for
general investing
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
if you're looking for ways to update
your home without blowing the budget
i've got it for years i've been telling
you about our friends at blinds.com
blinds.com makes it simple to shop top
quality blinds shades and interior
shutters from home with easy online
ordering and free shipping with
blinds.com there's no need to renovate
your entire home just change out what's
on your windows with upscale choices
like faux wood blinds cellular and
roller shades or even outdoor shades
plus blinds.com guarantees the perfect
fit whether you do it yourself or you
have them measure and install everything
for you shop their latest looks and see
how much you can save at blinds.com
today the easy and affordable way to
make your home more beautiful is
blinds.com
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm
ramsay personality rachel cruz hosting
at this hour and we're going to go to
the phones and daniel in dayton ohio is
up next hey daniel welcome to the show
thank you for having me on how are you
absolutely i'm doing great thanks for
calling how can i help
so i've been working on baby step two
working on my debt snowball awesome i've
already paid off a couple of my smaller
balances nice but
my largest credit card has a really high
interest rate and last month for the
first time the interest charge was
higher than my minimum payment by a
dollar oh my gosh
yeah so i was wondering if it would be
in my best interest to switch gears and
pay at least some of that down
just to get the interest under control
or if i should just keep plowing through
the snowball like normal but it'll
probably be about 16 months before i get
to that balance if i do it that way okay
so what other debts you have left
i have my car and i have another credit
card and then a couple thousand in
student loans okay and what what are the
balances on all those what are you on
your car
the
car is about ten thousand
uh the student loans are about two
thousand and the other credit card is
about four thousand okay
and how much do you make a year
fifty five thousand okay that's awesome
okay so obviously you're gonna be paying
off the student loan the 2000 are you
doing the debt snowball by paying off
the smallest loan first
all of your debt yeah i've paid off a
couple small ones already uh and i'm
working on you know going up to the next
one yeah
but but that one credit card is
bothering you because of the interest
rate and all that yeah you know daniel i
i i'm still gonna suggest just plowing
through the debt snowball i mean what
you've been doing you've been seeing the
traction that you're getting and even
though it's frustrating mathematically
of what's happening um the idea of still
knocking out that student loan getting
that out of the way because there's
something too about not just gaining the
momentum of paying the smallest one off
first but there's something even just
checking it off the list we're like you
don't even have to think about it
anymore and getting and thankfully you
know your student loans is only two
thousand dollars which is amazing for a
lot of people it's you know sometimes
even six figures so to start knocking
those out it's still gonna give you that
momentum and so continue to pay the
minimum payments um but i would i would
still i would still keep the debt
snowball method going because it works i
mean over time even though i know
mathematically it's frustrating um with
that one credit card but over the scope
of it you're still going to be gaining
that momentum and once that student
loans paid off obviously that minimum
payment's freed up to keep rolling over
so
that would be for sure my suggestion but
thanks for the call
and it's a good question because this
whole idea of of
money you know a lot of people think
it's like the dollars and the sense and
the math where so much more of you guys
its behavior it is so much about that
behavior change and when you can start
to feel anything emotionally with money
on the positive end of like getting that
traction getting that stability and just
knowing things are getting knocked off
it does something it gives you more
sleep at night it gives you more peace
and so uh keep attacking it that way
daniel but great question
all right next is andrew from
minneapolis hey andrew welcome to the
show
hi
hi andrew you're from rochester i'm
sorry
i messed up your city yeah i apologize
welcome how can i help so
my current issue is
i have about six months to a year before
i'm kicked out i'm currently living with
my parents i'm 25. i've got 10 000 in
the bank but i have 20 000 worth of debt
okay
and you're trying to figure out if i
should buy a home or go and rent
somewhere uh the lowest rent currently
from me in my area
like the lowest end possible is about
1200 a month okay
um i would for sure rent andrew um
because it's not just the rent that
you're thinking about when you go and
own a home there's all the other
expenses that come with it that you may
not even be thinking about and so
that home ownership it is it's so
expensive and it takes a new level of
responsibility so
what um you said are your parents
kicking you out did you guys have like a
timeline in place or what happened there
uh yeah so it was um you know
because i'm almost you know 26 you know
being a single guy it's not really
attractive you know living at home with
the folks all that much so failure
failure to launch is what uh as i'm
thinking about your smart man andrew
your smart man
yes exactly
so what do you do for work
uh so i work in a hospital with 3d
printing i make about 72k a year that's
great
very cool so yeah if i'm you if i woke
up in your shoes um
you could keep this keep going the six
months of your parents but i think you
have the ability to go still out on your
own so go find an apartment because i
think too and you kind of alluded to
this so i know you're feeling it but
there's the sense of dignity of like all
right i'm on my own like i'm paying my
bills and i'm doing it and so
getting that for you i think is really
important so even if you wanted to move
to an apartment or renting a house or
wherever you're gonna go renting wise
earlier than the six months
i think would be totally appropriate you
can do that
and then you have a great savings so i
would
take
some of that and throw it at your debt
and i would go ahead and just bring your
savings down to um just a thousand
dollars and start working on that debt
what's the 20 000 in debt again what's
the debt it's on student loans
yeah
yeah so i it's already
a quarter down of what it was originally
so that's awesome congratulations and
that's your only date you have
oh yes you only did a half that's
amazing yeah so i would throw 9 000 at
that
and just kind of keep chipping away
because um
because a lot's gonna be freed up for
you for sure when uh yeah when you pay
that off so congratulations
enjoy that enjoy that rental house
andrew i think that's a great a great
move and then once you're debt-free and
you have a fully funded emergency fund
you can save up for a down payment there
for your home
all right up next is jyn from des moines
hey jen welcome to the show
hey thanks for having me absolutely how
can i help
so i'm a mom of two kids two and three
and a half year old so they're little
and my husband and i are realizing more
and more that we need to think about how
we teach them about money
and when
you are know yourself know your money
book came out i've got it from the
library and realized like i grew up in a
kind of stressful household related to
money
and i know a lot of families just don't
talk about it so the kids don't know
about money for us um so my question for
you is how do i talk to them about money
with my kids so they grow up to have a
secure relationship with money yeah it's
a great question um and i love that
you're asking it because it is it's so
important and how to do this wisely and
um and do it well so i would say one
thing jen is that more is caught
than taught
so your kids are watching you and your
example
is huge i mean i think a lot of people
think growing up as dave ramsey's kid
that
you know our household we were like
obsessed with money and all we did was
talk about money and
we had like mutual fund birthday parties
and like like everything was around
money and that was not the case thank
the lord um it was not the case mom and
dad i mean they they talked to us about
it sure and they taught us and we had
some responsibility here and there but
it was nothing
like extreme out of the ordinary and so
i would say as much as you can make it
um
as as organic as possible in the ebb and
flow of life and so i feel like a lot of
parents you know they have such good
intention of teaching their kids about
money but it ends up being this
unauthentic un an organic like sit down
and we're gonna explain all this to you
like twice a year and
and it just becomes this almost robotic
feel right where it's almost can lean
like legalistic or something and so i
think with your kids again your example
you and your husband's example is going
to be the biggest they are watching you
and then number two just talking to them
especially when they're small
and again three and a half and two like
they're super small but when they're
getting you know yeah six seven eight
years old and starting to show them
things and and talk about it i mean even
small things like at the grocery store
even my kids like literally just
happened this week
at the store and it was like the honey
nut cheerios it was like buy one get one
free and i was like girls did you know
you could buy
for this store specifically i could buy
this and get a free box or if i don't
buy the if i don't get the second box i
get this box half off they you know and
i'm like sitting there and just teaching
them it's like these little things these
little tips and tricks throughout life
that you're just bringing them in
appropriately and then the three
or really the four lessons with teaching
kids again age appropriately but work
give save and spend
and those are the three things you have
to remember and even as adults that's
really what you do with money is you
work you make your money
and you really can just give it you can
save it invest it and you can spend it
and so looking at all three of those
buckets but again jen for you i mean i
wouldn't i wouldn't start all that until
they're probably
five six years old um but up until now
yeah just letting them see hey money
comes from work even something just that
simple when they're young can go a
really really long way so great question
thanks for the call this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
if you're considering a career in
technology i recommend bethel tech and
i'm not alone here's what brendan said
before bethel tech i was driving uber
within four months of graduating i got a
job paying sixty thousand dollars about
two years after that i got a remote job
that pays me a hundred and thirty
thousand dollars all thanks to what i
learned at bethel tech you could be next
get started today at
betheltech.net and get one thousand to
twenty five hundred dollars off of your
tuition again it's betheltech.net
ken coleman
[Music]
we're live on the debt-free stage here
at ramsey solutions in nashville
tennessee is dominic and julie from
burlington wisconsin welcome you guys hi
there rachel hello
well i mean i guess there's one reason
you're standing on that stage right yes
congratulations thank you completely
debt-free okay
so you guys are in wisconsin and you
made your way here yeah to nashville so
how much debt did you guys pay off so
it's really debt-free times two whoa i
can't wait to hear
um 263
465 dollars and 64 cents
love i love when people get down to the
penny it's so good so really it's
we graduated college in 06. okay it took
us four and a half years to pay off 78
000 roughly of student loan debt yeah so
we're completely debt free
saved up our down payment um and then in
the last 10 years paid that off oh my
gosh so this includes the mortgage
you're completely debt free correct
amazing you guys
congratulations as we always say around
here i'm like i'm looking at weird
people you don't have a mortgage correct
you don't have a mortgage okay and so
how long did it take you 16 about 15
years 15 years to pay it all off
through that time three kids about a
hundred thousand cash flowed in house
repairs new cars
all that kind of stuff oh yeah you're
living life in 15 years while you're
doing this and how much was your income
during that time which will i know be
very different so starting out when we
graduated i was making 39 000 a year
and then last year 163 yeah and then
this year probably close to 180. oh my
gosh
amazing you guys okay so what do y'all
do for a living so i'm an accountant
accountant and she stays at home and
manages the house yeah that's wonderful
you know our one of our top three
careers that we found in our millionaire
study and to give and to give you uh
insight she went to school to be a
teacher oh there you go you're you
you're the devil the teacher account yes
right
that's amazing you guys
okay so the type of debt it was it was
student loans mortgage anything else
nope that was it okay was the house so
what happens so in college
um we were went to school in grand
rapids michigan yeah and so in oh five
um i started listening to the show we
got married in oh four wow um went to
dave's live event in grand rapids in o5
yeah i might have been there yep i think
you might have been working there uh
high school rachel may have been there
yeah we worked then we went in 07 as
well yeah and then when we graduated
started paying off the debt led four fpu
classes oh wow also led uh your
generation change that you were a big
part of yes so dang it youth group yeah
you all been around been around the
ramsey block or two in the sense yeah
that's amazing you guys absolutely
amazing so you guys just finally said
you know what
we're gonna just knock out this mortgage
we're gonna we're gonna be done with it
and be completely completely debt free
so so you started listening to the show
in college like you said and then just
kept getting involved so as a
coordinator
did that help the motivation continue on
yeah that's really for the question the
biggest cheerleader it's it's the fpu
class all the members that went through
it that we taught and if you're going to
teach you have to do it yeah and then um
also all the doubters along the way were
big cheerleaders as well yeah so they
and they appreciate it they do did you
have a lot of doubters do people think
you're crazy for trying to pay off your
mortgages
throughout the years yeah yeah for sure
okay so julie for you
going through this experience with your
husband to pay off debt you know money
we say it all the time around here but
it's just true it causes so much tension
and couples so for you guys how did you
work as a couple
to do this because i'm assuming are
y'all are y'all both spenders both
savers vice versa what's the i'm the
spender yeah my family yeah i appreciate
you um i feel like i grew up in a frugal
household and so that helped a lot when
it came down to budgeting
and sacrificing so that definitely
helped um
there wasn't too many arguments i mean i
felt like we were on the same page a lot
of the time yeah so yeah we worked well
together yeah the the the thing is we we
really grew up together so we we were
dated in high school yeah married after
our sophomore year of college so we we
started with nothing together and built
everything that we have and did it yes
amazing okay so what did it feel like
when you made that last so mortgage
payment
we we literally loaded the kids into the
car went to the bank said take the money
out of the savings
pay it off we're done
and we just went home and went out for
ice cream
called it today
isn't it funny i feel like i feel like
the consumer debt like when that's paid
off it's like this you know crazy
celebration which we obviously celebrate
all of it but i've heard a few people
recently if with the mortgage it's like
oh the thought of not having a mortgage
payment is it on in a totally different
sphere in my mind but the payoff is like
oh yeah well we just did it and we did
it you know what i mean like that kind
of thing so that's awesome that is
awesome so what what would you tell
someone who's listening
and they're thinking
y'all are crazy like i would rather just
enjoy my life right now it's not a big
deal i mean it's your house everyone has
a mortgage
what encouragement would you give them
it's it's worth it on this end um hard
work you know it just it breeds the next
thing so now it's what are we doing next
what's the next goal and continue moving
along that path so absolutely do you
guys have anything fun that you're going
to be doing in the next 12 or so months
well if we could travel a little more
that would be nice
really we're saving up to do more
remodels on the house okay okay continue
off the house that's amazing well you
guys i mean
it's huge you completely change your
family tree the legacy that is left of
what your kids witnessed as you guys
were doing this journey um
yeah you can't put a price on it you
can't and for you guys that did the
diligence of
working the plan and paying it off i
mean i'm so excited for you guys so
proud absolutely incredible all right
and you got your kids here right yeah so
bring them up
oh sorry okay what are their names and
ages madeleine 13 nicholas 11 and hattie
is eight amazing you guys absolutely
incredible well you did what some would
say is the impossible and
with the focus and intensity you guys
did it so congratulations uh we're gonna
give you a copy of baby steps
millionaires because that is the next uh
part of your journey and a total money
makeover to give away to someone to
continue to help but you guys have been
helping people all along the way by
being financial peace coordinators which
is just incredible
oh so i'm so excited to say to count it
down again dominic and julie paid off
236
000 that includes their mortgage over 15
years making 39 000 all the way up to
almost 180 000
count it down let's hear your debt free
scream three
two
one we're done
oh my gosh amazing absolutely amazing
i love that and again people are like
what
that's not possible that's not possible
to pay off your mortgage you're gonna
just keep on you're gonna just have it
forever
but a lot of student loans completely
paid off which some people think that's
impossible as well and then knocking out
the mortgage and not
having
a mortgage payment i'm like it
you can do anything they can do anything
and you guys listening out there
you can do this if you are freaked out
and you're stuck and you're listening to
everything going on out in the world and
you feel like you can't control your
life you don't know what's going on you
feel out of control you're stuck in
these debt payments and you think it has
to be a part of your life it doesn't it
doesn't
and dominic and julie they are a picture
of it
because it's going to take everyone a
different amount of time everyone's
going to have a different level of
income during it a different amount of
debt coming into these journeys but but
we've heard it all you guys we've heard
it all here on the ramsey show every
amount possible
even up to
paying off a mortgage
because you know what you can do when
you have no payments
anything you want you get to go and you
won't know you don't owe anyone anything
and the amount of freedom that comes
with that with just not the financial
freedom that it frees up your income
which is your largest wealth building
tool
but it frees up your mind it frees up
your spirit it frees up
uh your sleep at night i mean it changes
everything and your options and margin
all of those things are on your side
versus living in that rat wheel of just
payment after payment after payment and
shaking it up
and we say it again i said it to them
but but it's weird like that's not
normal it's not normal to think i could
really work hard and sacrifice and get
out of debt what's normal is to think
well this has to be my life and it
doesn't you get to make a decision and
that's the beautiful thing you get to
make a decision and they made decisions
day in and day out for 15 years you guys
but guess what they don't have any
payments so congratulations to them
again this is the ramsey show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
blinds.com a hundred
satisfaction guarantee means that if
even if you mismeasure or pick the wrong
color they will remake your blinds for
free you get free samples free shipping
and with the new promo codes they run
every month you will save even more so
use promo code ramsey to get the best
deal
and today's question comes from chris
and maryland
i use credit cards for their rewards
i look at getting them
wait i look at it like getting revenge
on the credit card companies for all the
money that i paid them an interest so
long before i started being responsible
they
had no problem charging me 25 interest
and missed fee and late fees if i missed
a payment so
now i get all the rewards and i can make
up for the money that they got out of me
if i had paid them five thousand dollars
in interest over the years and collected
more of that in rewards i come out ahead
what do you think about this mindset
chris listen they're winning in life
like
like like do you see their buildings do
you see the banks buildings around like
the they're you're not you're not
getting them like you're five thousand
dollars you think it's making a dent
uh in the side of them and it's just not
and so
for me let me just tell you
study after study has been proven that
you spend more when you spend with
credit cards okay that's just a fact
it's 12 to 18
or more
according to dun bradstreet that was
done just a few years ago that study so
you're going to spend more with credit
cards even if you think i'm going to get
them with the rewards you're spending
more
period
so you're getting the rewards for
spending more money versus saying hey
i'm just going to pay
for what i want with cash with my debit
card
and then whatever reward i was going to
get from the credit card company
i'm probably going to say i'm going to
have saved because i use my own money
that amount or even more to make up my
own rewards over here so so for me i
just know you end up spending more i
also know that your perspective when you
use credit cards even if you say you pay
them off every month which a new study
came out that up to they said almost 28
of americans are the only ones that
actually pay off their balance in full
every month so majority of people do not
they carry a balance
but that mindset of well if i pay it off
every month but still even if you do
okay even if you do pay yourself every
month there is still this idea that at
the end of the month and you pay that
bill you are still paying for things
that you have already experienced that
is foods you've already eaten movies
you've already seen vacations you've
already taken you are literally living
your life in a rear view mirror versus
if you said i'm actually going to just
when i spend money i'm going to spend my
own money and it's coming out of my bank
account in the moment and that's how i'm
going to live you end up living in the
present and even in the future because
when you budget you're looking ahead to
say hey what am i going to be doing
there and you're casting a vision you
have a plan going forward
versus continuing to look back and
that's what you do i had a friend who
was hardcore on this stuff for years and
we went out to dinner with them a few
months ago and he was like rachel i
gotta confess i got a southwest credit
card i was like it's i mean like i'm
like
like i'm not gonna yell at you like we
can we're still gonna be friends and go
to dinner and all of that you know uh
he's like i know i know but i just like
i need to tell you i was like that's
fine you don't have to tell me
well fast forward until um like two
weeks after that
we were talking uh him and his wife and
us and he said because i actually ended
up cutting up that credit card i told
you i got and i was like oh really he's
like yeah i had it for about three
months
and he said and i realized
how much more i just i just spent
subconsciously like
we went to the athletic store and my
kids needed new jerseys
for the team and you know this
professional team that they're getting
jerseys for
and he's like and i found myself being
like oh we'll get the nicer ones yeah
because it's only like you know 20 bucks
more it's not that big of a video here
go and he's like and i just ended up
subconsciously just just spending a
little bit more because the emotional
tie of not spending my own money was so
real and so true
and when you know it's your money coming
out of your account you just spend money
differently
and then the last thing i'll say it's
credit card rant man it
and some people are like oh that doesn't
bother me but it does bother me because
here's because because chris you're
getting these rewards
and all of this because of people who
have mismanaged their money people that
are mismanaging their money you're
benefiting from their mismanagement for
your own self and to me it's gross it's
a toxic environment it's a toxic
industry that i'm like no i want nothing
to do with it i'm good like i have a
debit card i've never had a credit card
i'm alive i'm breathing air and you can
still survive today and just spend your
own money and not even mess and play
with the game so to me i want nothing to
do with them so chris um i don't like
your mindset
you asked what did you think about your
mindset i don't like it i don't like it
there's my answer
all right we're gonna go to the phones
and lauren from indianapolis is up next
hey lauren welcome to the show
hi mitchell hi
absolutely how can i help i love i love
your books um thank you my husband and i
have been listening to the show for two
years now um and we've made like a lot
of huge changes we've awesome paid off
about 55 000 on our mortgage wow amazing
just merged all of our bank accounts
finally after being married for five
years yeah
and i pretty much went cold turkey and
stopped using my credit card last month
finally
done it lauren converted all the way
we've done a lot of stuff and um so we
have a hundred and thirty one thousand
dollars left on our mortgage okay and um
we're kind of facing this dilemma where
we're looking at our income and like i
really want to be gazelle intense about
it like i want to get it gone as soon as
possible
um but we also recognize we need to save
for things for the future like a roof
and siding and a future car
um so i'm trying to wrap my head around
approaching the mortgage payoff um and
we want to have a life too i mean we've
been super frugal recently
um so i'm just going to try to wrap my
head around that because we want to be
mortgage-free as soon as possible yeah
for sure we also don't want to
completely yep totally destroy our live
new process for sure and how much do you
guys make a year
um we have a household income of 185.
okay
so here's what we say lauren on baby
steps one and no other debt i'm assuming
right you guys no no i did that okay so
baby steps one through three which is
your thousand dollar emergency fund
getting completely debt free but your
mortgage and your fully funded emergency
fund those are your gazelle intensity
moments like those those are the steps
that it's like you're you don't have any
life right like what kind of what you're
saying you're like you're not going out
you're not going shopping no vacation
you're doing nothing
you're literally focusing all of your
energy all of your effort all of your
money
on those steps one at a time and then
once you get past baby step three we say
you can kind of take your foot off the
gas pedal right you're gonna be doing
other things you're gonna be funding
retirement you're gonna be uh if you
guys have kids even looking into kids
college and then again throwing extra at
the mortgage so so this includes having
somewhat of a life too lauren like you
guys
saving up for a vacation is totally
appropriate if you need to replace a car
yes all of this is appropriate so so the
way i look at it um and what i would
encourage you and your husband to do is
to look ahead and say okay
what what year or even down to the month
do we want to be completely debt free
like not have a mortgage right we just
had a debt-free call just the segment
before and they paid off their mortgage
which is amazing yes so yeah just to say
okay realistically
where can we like you know enjoy life
because you've worked hard to enjoy life
you guys have made the sacrifices to get
to this point
um but we really really really want that
house paid off and just look ahead and
find a date that feels right to you guys
that's not the 15-year you know mortgage
date i have a date i have one picked out
and stuff and like made a tracker and
everything okay see okay so is that
how's that feeling
it feels good like i think it's doable i
mean it's an extra two thousand dollars
a month on our mortgage we already
refinanced
um we we refinanced from like a 30 to a
15 and then we had an opportunity to do
basically a free finance down to eight
years oh wow okay even if we just kept
our i was like 40 or something even if
we just kept on our regular payment with
the eight year mortgage that we
refinanced to yep we'd be paid off 2027
but if we
paid if we doubled down we'd be paid off
by the end of 2024 which is what i'd
really like to do okay so i think that's
great and i think you and your husband
sitting down and deciding hey this this
this date feels right it feels like we
have enough
breathing room to be able to do things
that we want and that we know are going
to be coming up you know like replacing
a roof and all that that you explained
yeah um so it gives you a little bit of
that breathing room but it also gives
you enough aggression that you're like
yeah we can get this we can get this
paid off so it sounds like you guys
are completely on the right track and if
you and your husband are agreed upon on
that date i would say keep try keep
going forward because
you're never going to look back and like
we sacrificed too much right like once
you have paid off the mortgage you're
thinking oh my gosh
for a short amount of time we sacrificed
our life and now we have no payments and
we can take that mortgage payment and do
whatever we want with it and it's an
amazing thing amazing thing so thanks
for the call lauren
thanks to everyone in the booth for
helping me out this hour this is the
ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your debt
free stream live on the show visit
ramseysolutions.com
debt free screen we'd love for you to
come to nashville and tell dave your
story that's ramsey solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
ramsey personality rachel cruz
co-hosting today
with the one and only ken coleman ken
yes best-selling author ramsey
personality your own host of your own
show yeah yeah just your friend and my
friend just your friend a couple desks
over the old pal can yeah you know what
your your political conversation friend
now that is true we love to have a good
conversation during election season ken
and i are like two jabbering true stores
anytime there's a major debate on i'm
gonna get anywhere from 10 to 15 texts
from you
that's always fun we both love politics
we do um but give us a call you guys
triple a
825-525 it's a free call anywhere and
these days we're talking about more than
just your money we're talking about your
career with ken here especially um
please call in with that because he is
the best when it comes to unpacking what
your passions are where you need to be
guided to in your career
the career part of your life as well as
relationships and mental health all of
it so we are here for the discussion so
we're gonna go to the phones and dawn
from traverse city is up next hey dawn
welcome to the show
happy friday you guys happy friday dawn
how can we help
dave is always talking to
invest for the long run
uh long term
i don't have i'm 56
and i've only been investing in
for the last couple years but
since 2020 i have matched i'll
max out on my ira
and um i've got some stocks and bonds
being done through my investor
and i'm wondering i'm investing 22 a
month
and i'm wondering if i back that off to
15
and then i could start giving
to organizations
um
i'm not debt free
because i sold my house last fall to
moving into an apartment because my
health doesn't uh allow me to maintain a
home anymore so i'm always going to have
rental
costs
okay
so
and what any guidance uh what other debt
do you have
nothing
oh you have no other debt i'm sorry
no all my other debt was paid off in
2020 okay and then i sold my house in
december last december and what caused
you to sell the home
uh my health i'm not i needed to see
another physician that wasn't in our
area okay and it wasn't me
being single i wasn't able to maintain
the house anymore okay okay i'm sorry i
know that's kind of that's a hard
transition but i think that's that's
wise and i'm and i'm proud of you for
doing that because sometimes that can be
difficult um
yeah well to answer just the
your main question of the investing i i
kind of perked up when you said that
your financial guy has stocks and bonds
so i just want to make sure that what
you're putting towards the money you're
putting towards investing
is going the furthest for you
and to be at 57 i would really be on
this because
depending on what i mean i know what
bonds are but what they mean by stocks i
know if that's single stocks or what it
is so i don would go and take a whole
look of the picture of your investment
strategy and making sure that you're
that you're maxing out you know uh you
said you have your ira which is great
um and and looking at any other vehicles
of retirement and then looking into
mutual funds because you're gonna get
better rates of return
doing those things versus just sitting
in bonds that don't create a lot it
feels like a lot of safety i'm sure for
your financial advisor for you because
of your age but you still have the
ability to go a little bit more
aggressive
and to even make more so so i would um i
would back it down a little bit for sure
if you want to but making sure that that
money is being invested in something
that is going to give you a good rate of
return don i'm curious how much do you
have saved for retirement right now
i just got my statement and it is at 74
000
and i meet with my financial officer
next week okay
well he would like to cash out the
stocks because i i was with marathon
petroleum and he feels now that it might
crash that went from five thousand to
fourteen thousand i just bought that
uh in uh yeah the single stocks
i'm not yeah so don rachel's right we we
don't want you in single stocks because
of the volatility it is a form of
gambling
uh in that you are putting yourself at
tremendous risk one of the things that
we want you to do we want to get you
connected to a smart investor pro i want
you to go to ramseysolutions.com
at the end of the call and i want you to
take a few minutes to get the names of
several folks uh i'd like you to look at
three at a uh minimum and i want you to
have a meeting with them because uh
these are people who dave trusts and you
called say you know dave has said this
for years on investing so we put this
system in place to be able to send folks
like you to men and women who can really
guide you through this because we've got
a couple things going on here first
you're 57 and you've got you've only got
74 000 so you need to be aggressive the
your question was i'm giving i thought
you said twenty percent of your income
you've been putting twenty percent of
your income into stocks and bonds is
that correct did i hear you correctly um
twenty-two percent
every month
to end it's um
he has he gets to select what funds that
they go into i understand i can't
contribute anymore to my ira okay so
here's the point though i don't want you
to start focusing on giving i want you
to first focus on getting with a smart
investor pro i really want you to
interview a few folks okay i don't like
the advice you're being given i'm not
trying to be unkind okay but i don't
think it's good advice for a 57 year old
single lady
and the other question i have is is uh
your health is it impacting your ability
to work full-time
yes i've been disabled since
uh 1995. okay uh my
my employer's just long-term disability
and long-term uh social security and
they froze my
retirement
and then a couple just a couple years
ago they sent a letter saying
i could keep it with them but i'd be no
longer grandfathered in or i could roll
it over so that's when i rolled it over
and then that's when i started
contributing to it got you okay so you
have a limited income uh through your
disability and as well as your social
security so i really want you to be
maximizing these dollars please please
please ramsay solutions.com
and uh
interview multiple people rachel why do
we tell people to do that well you want
to be able to make sure that you have
someone that you trust because this this
is a part of money that a lot of people
get kind of like oh about because john
and what you just said is very common
where it's like yeah i'm kind of
trusting these people with everything
i don't really know why they're doing it
i kind of understand but i don't and you
want someone that's in your corner that
has the heart of a teacher
and they can sit there and teach you and
explain every single thing and why
they're doing it and and the people that
we trust when they they
go about the investing advice that that
we give here at ramsey again to set you
up
for the for the best future possible
because we want you to get from point a
to point b and that is winning with
money becoming wealthy being able to
retire with dignity don which i know you
want to do all of these things and so we
really do have a great group of people
that help america with that our smart
investor pros so i would don but that
the investing conversation it's
intimidating and it's hard and it so
making sure you have someone in your
corner that you trust and you feel good
about is really important so don
make sure to check them out but thanks
for calling this is the ramsay show
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
look i love real estate and i want you
to have a house but i don't want a house
to have
you
that's why you need to get in touch with
churchill mortgage to make sure you do
this right these guys are awesome
they'll help you get on a smarter
mortgage plan because they're committed
to doing what's right for
you
that means they check in every year with
free consultations to help you stay on
the right plan they show you how to save
money and interest so you can build
wealth faster they walk you through the
total cost of your loan so you can make
the best choice
basically they care that's why we call
them ramsey trusted you can achieve
debt-free home ownership and churchill
is here to help go to their site
churchillmortgage.com
ramsey to start your approval or get
more information
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i am
ramsey personality rachel cruz hosting
today with
ramsay personality best-selling author
ken coleman
all right up next is megan from dayton
ohio hey megan welcome to the show
hi how are you guys today we're doing
great how are you
good thank you for taking my call
absolutely um so i had a question
um we are i guess currently in baby step
seven and
we
yeah it's so exciting um and
we bought this house um in 2015 and we
absolutely love it but we are looking in
the future
to hopefully having
like a ranch out on a few acres of land
um to do some like gardening and
chickens and all that good stuff
um so my thought process is i'm trying
to you know you have so many people so
many opinions so much media and
i guess my question is is it better to
buy sooner with less down
or
wait and save cash but risk like the
inflation in the house is going up you
know in the next what would probably
take about four to five years to save up
that money to
get the bump up how much is your current
house worth
i'm sitting at about 225
and what would the ranch properties set
you back
um they're looking at about 350
you know give or take depending on which
city which we're flexible and because we
don't have kids so school system and
that doesn't exactly um is not a factor
how much money do you guys make a year
megan what's your income um we're
looking at about 90 000. okay
um well i mean if you have 122 000
and you're wanting to go 350 it's 150
000 mortgage it's kind of what you look
at it um yeah and
so you have more than enough to put down
i mean i would i would just
completely say hey just take the equity
in the home and throw it at the new
house and then you guys have 150 to pay
down um if that's what you want to do so
it's i mean at this point it's it's kind
of a
decision on what's best for you and your
family and what you guys want
uh at this because it's not completely
outrageous numbers i'd like to see the
mortgage be a little bit less i mean i
hate before you going back in that's
what i want to know rachel so megan when
you called
i know you're asking our opinion but
which way were you leaning were you
feeling any sense of guilt because
you've worked so hard to walk the baby
steps out and your baby steps seven and
that's so exciting and all of a sudden
you're going i don't want to take it
yeah okay so that's where you yeah
because i i don't want another mortgage
but yeah all right you know we have we
have the goal of paying it off before we
were 30 and i was 29 in nine months and
so that was a really big deal so going
into another mortgage is like takes your
breath away because okay so that is a
lot all right so megan
so how many years i think you said it
did you say two or three more years to
be able to save up the money to pay cash
for the ranch did i hear that it would
it would most likely be four to five
okay so hold on a second so you asked
that question you said do i take this
smaller mortgage out which you've
already told us what you feel and why
you feel it and we understand that i
wouldn't go backwards because i think
you've got a false narrative and i want
to help you through this
waiting four to five years
to save up that money to be able to pay
cash for the dream
you're not going to pay that much more
you really aren't um this idea of
inflation i know inflation is freaking
everybody out it's like the new thing
and everybody's throwing around this way
that way the reality is that real estate
increases
um
are due to supply demand
not inflationary prices driving that up
as much where we see inflation really
hit people and kind of fluctuating go up
and down is in things like
groceries gasoline things of that nature
the real estate market is the real
estate market is it going to go up
in the next four to five years in the
dayton ohio area well i think it would
just by we see historical norms there
but in the grand scheme of things the
amount of money that that ranch that
dream if you've got that in your mind
the amount of money that's going to go
up four to five years
isn't that going to prohibit you from
being able to pay cash for it yeah and i
would say megan too that this 90 grand
is not gonna stay flat for four to five
years either you're gonna be making more
um as you guys continue down and so all
of that so yes so i i i'm leaning with
ken on this one too where i'm like man
just go back in and say 150 000 which
again and the grand scheme of a mortgage
doesn't feel like crazy amount and and
we've told people on the show before if
you're gonna take out you know maybe
take out a little mortgage to make a
move you really want you know it's not
something we're gonna yell at you for
but i think looking to say okay how much
can we save up and when that's your
mindset it's amazing the different
decisions you make in life
versus just defaulting to oh yeah we'll
just take out a mortgage for the
difference so um i i would i would hold
still megan and i wouldn't let all these
outside factors just like what ken was
saying drive your decision because a lot
of that's based on fear
and obviously there's facts happening
that we're seeing the inflation we're
seeing the supply and demand issue but i
think even when you get to that point of
of five year four or five years
you can kind of see it start to shake
out and i do think even with real estate
again we don't have a crystal ball so i
don't want to predict anything because i
was very famous of predicting the end of
covid that was going to be july of 2020.
you were famous for that i was like i
know that covet will be over in july
that's what i said at one point i
remember i'm like i will never predict
never again i will never again predict
the future but i do think this housing
thing is bizarre and the amount of
what's going on so i think once the
supply and demand issue is fixed and
there's more homes being built and the i
mean it all kind of does
stable out so i would take a breath
megan and i wouldn't make a decision
based on all these outside factors and
let me just say this megan you also
mentioned that
there's other people we heard it when
you listed out the kind of all these
types of opinions there are friends and
family members who have tremendous
influence on you and that's normal but
you've got to do what's right for you so
i think rachel said it right i don't
think that there's anything wrong with
either one of these decisions but it's
very clear to raise one eye what's right
for you you said it you don't want to
ever have a mortgage again so you
determine what's right in this situation
that's right all right up next is jordan
from salt lake city hey jordan welcome
to the show
hey guys happy friday and thank you so
much for taking my call absolutely
thanks for calling how can we help
so rachel i saw your story on instagram
yeah girl today
thanks jordan all of a sudden i'm left
out let me pull up your story
i went on instagram because i hosted
last hour by myself and i said oh i saw
that and i said instagram help me out
and jordan she called she got what's
what do the kids say she got the memo
where she got the assignment she
understood the assignment i don't think
the kids say either one she understood
okay jordan let us help you let us help
you
well um i am 33 years old and my husband
and i have three kids um eight four and
one
and um i have been going through a
debate for the past i guess
two years my husband and i moved out
from tennessee here to utah um beginning
of 2020 and i had actually planned to
stop working at that time and just kind
of you know see what happens maybe stay
home with the kids and because of code i
was actually able to continue doing my
job from home because everything started
to go remote yeah and i've been able to
continue working as a clinical
pharmacist
from home wow and i've been making about
120 to 130 per year oh wow my husband
yeah my husband is an engineer for the
government and he makes 120 a year but
he is projected to go up on his income
each year
um
and so i've been wondering for a while
now if i should stay home with the kids
because
um you know they're getting older and i
feel like i'm missing out on things but
at the same time i love my job i love
working yeah um my contract is set to
end at the end of june okay um
and
you know i'm just kind of torn whether i
should keep working or yeah i should
stay home i think one of the best pieces
of advice i got when i um was a mom with
three and kind of was like oh gosh i
don't know what's i don't know what to
do you know because you're kind of
pulled in all these directions
is life is so seasonal jordan there it's
so seasonal so even if you said hey i'm
gonna work till the end of june and i'm
gonna just pause for two years for two
years until the kids get in
school or what you know whatever that
time frame is and then i can reevaluate
and then once they're in school
full-time it's like oh well this maybe i
can pick up some more you know what i
mean like it doesn't have to be this all
or nothing for the rest of your life you
can have seasons right and so if you're
feeling this tug that you feel like
you've had
um and you guys financially are going to
be able to do it and it's not a big
burden for you as a family
um that that's that's a choice you
totally can make and say i'm gonna pause
for about two years on the work thing
focus on the kids and then i'm gonna
press play again
um later down the road because
uh you're right the kids are here in a
snapshot and moms that have that heart
to be home especially if you guys have
sacrificed and gotten out of debt and
have the ability to i think it's awesome
i think it's awesome and you can always
go back always go back to work jordan uh
but thanks for calling i so appreciate
it fellow instagram
followers hey
[Music]
love the gram
[Music]
chaos that's what it can feel like when
your business is growing so fast you've
outgrown your financial and accounting
software the faster you grow the more
likely you are to lose control of the
numbers and here's the reality if you
don't know your numbers you don't know
your business that's why we use netsuite
by oracle the number one cloud financial
system over 28 000 companies use
netsuite by oracle including ramsey
solutions because netsuite gives us a
single view of everything we need to
make daily decisions whether you're
making a few million to hundreds of
millions a year netsuite gives you the
visibility and control of the things you
need to grow like your financials
inventory hr planning budgeting and more
all in one dashboard go to netsuite.com
ramsey right now to get their free white
paper jumpstart your cfo career
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Applause]
well building wealth is a hot topic
right now everyone is talking about it
everyone has an opinion on it so whether
it's crypto or single stocks or zero
down real estate or the metaverse man
everyone is just freaking out about all
these new things that are happening
and so that is why we decided to take
our building wealth live event on the
road this year so
vegas orlando we are coming to you here
in the next few weeks and then we're
going to be going to sacramento
minneapolis and san antonio this fall
and so we're going to tackle all of
these kind of get rich quick schemes and
dive into saving investing in retirement
and really talk about how do you build
wealth how do you build wealth that
stays with you that's not fleeting but
really does help you
change your life change your family tree
and be extremely generous to others so
we're going to be in vegas may 5th
orlando may 19th and then in the fall
sacramento november 1st minneapolis
november 10th and san antonio november
15th and it's going to be dave ramsey
george campbell myself dr john deloney
and ken coleman we're all going on the
road we're hitting the road again ken
it's right and i'm thinking about
renting a elvis costume for the vegas
event it hasn't been approved by
leadership yet but i think it'd be a fun
moment if you came out no the the booth
is saying i think it'd be great i think
it'd be great we'll see so you guys come
uh check out those events our our live
events are always fun we they enjoy it
we have fun and
we want to laugh and learn and hang out
with you guys so here's what's fun about
that building wealth event a little
tease yeah there's some table talk yeah
all of us together
and you kind of you kind of um you kind
of moderate and make it happen i'm i'm
i'm a moderator
no no but you talk too
i mean you're talking you're not just oh
that's fair i guess moderators yeah i
know i have an opinion and then
we know so
we know so this one's gonna be fun it's
gonna be great so dave does like a
keynote at the front end of the event
and then the back of the event it is
just all of us literally sitting at a
table and talking through these topics
that are so big and so it's it's fun
it's just it's our version of the view
yes yes yeah should be fun oh so great
so tickets are just twenty five dollars
or you can get a four pack
uh for sixty dollars so you can bring
friends again it's gonna be amazing go
to ramsaysolutions.com
events to get your tickets again ramsay
solutions dot com slash events okay so
ken you uh
had this article and we're talking about
this topic which i thought was just
fascinating
about the number one concern yeah of
american employees yeah gallup recently
pulled over 13 000 american employees to
ask them what was most important to them
when deciding to accept a new job or not
now this is uh very relevant because
we're still in what they're calling the
great resignation just to give people
who aren't familiar with the term what
that actually means is that since august
of 2021 rachel we've had almost 30
million people change jobs
okay
it's extraordinary wages are up all
right because there is a high demand for
workers we have more open jobs available
in america right now than we have people
that are unemployed 3.4 unemployment so
these are all historic things and so the
labor market is quite hot in that
companies are offering much bigger
paychecks they are offering tuition full
tuition reimbursement they're offering
crazy benefits signing bonuses all this
so gallup pulled 13 000 people
and the number one concern for american
employees and taking a new job not
surprisingly 64 percent said a
significant increase
in income or benefits was very important
to them but here's the irony
all right they're saying that's the
number one thing but still feeling the
crunch of inflation yeah so paychecks
are bigger rachel
but
the overall
wealth or let's call it uh
money health
situation in america is as worse as it's
ever been credit card all-time high
um and what we talked about on the cake
how much on this deal is is that if you
make a move just for a paycheck and then
you're not managing
that increased paycheck correctly guess
what
you've got no benefit at all and you may
have made a move just for a bigger
paycheck and then you regret it in fact
we're seeing this in the data so what
we're seeing here is is that while we
understand why people want more pay what
they really want is more margin and
we're even seeing that
high income earners aren't immune to
this problem just because you get the
bigger paycheck doesn't mean you make
financial progress talk about that
it's one of the biggest myths out there
is like well if i just made more money
everything would be okay correct but
that's not always the case you guys no
because if you make more money and you
still have bad habits with money those
bad habits follow the more money like
it's it happens and so
yes some research some research found
that 64 of consumers
live paycheck to paycheck in january of
2022 and again inflation's at a whole
all-time high everything but 48 percent
of consumers earning more than a hundred
thousand dollars a year are living
paycheck to paycheck so that represents
a six percentage point increase from
december yeah so within one month
that big of a difference and and so yeah
we're seeing again half of income
earners
um
high income earners overs over six
figures are living paycheck to patients
what's happening is we're making more
but we're spending more and so what's
the solution to this it's what we teach
at ramsey solutions this idea of the
baby steps
you know if you've got debt uh if you
have no idea how you're spending your
money so we're talking about eliminating
debt which of course reduces your cost
we're talking about getting very clear
on where you're spending your money
what's the outgo what's it going to
that's budgeting these are all core
methodologies of the baby steps and it
really comes down to this financial
peace
is so vital to you being able to fund
your future
and you know i i'm struck by every time
we have a debt-free screen whether it's
an individual rachel or a couple uh once
we hear the story and we hear the
emotion and all the things and you get
on the other side of that and what
they're dreaming about what they're
planning for they can actually fund it
yes and do it and you guys i'm telling
you it's so not only does it give you
that level of freedom when you're in
control and you know what you're doing
but i can't stress it enough the
character that's built through this
process is so key that we just want
instant results we want instant
gratification
when we want something we want it now
and we don't um appreciate the process
through it all because again until
you're learning to change your habits
you're gonna be in the exact it's still
you it's still you
that's gonna be just getting more money
and it's gonna be funding more of your
bad habits so changing those habits
it is so crucial i remember when winston
and i we built a home and moved in
november of 19.
i don't know how we like
god's timing but we um i remember being
in our old kitchen it was right before
we moved and and we had um i was
pregnant with a third we had a little
one in a high chair and emily was
running around and food's everywhere and
they're just screaming i mean you're
just it's just chaos goldfish you're
stepping on goals it's just cold it's
just it's chaos been there and i
remember i looked over once and i was
like i just can't wait to be in my new
kitchen oh and he was like babe
this exact same scene is gonna be
happening in a little bit of a different
color kitchen it's gonna be a little bit
wider but it's true it's literally the
same thing and i was like i know and
like why in a split second do you feel
like
no if i go get something better
higher income whatever it is it's just
everything's gonna be okay but you're
the person you're in it you're still in
it a better kitchen doesn't mean a
better life
that's your next book how do you like it
oh sure
yeah yeah i could get three pages out of
that if i try really hard uh but i do
think that when people think i get a
better better paycheck i'm gonna get a
better life and that's absolutely not
the case because what happens is with a
bigger paycheck watch this
instead of bigger paycheck equals better
life here's what happens bigger paycheck
means bigger problems
not too much because we mo money no
problem mo money mo problems man that's
good there now there's got to bump out
with that there's the book title
mo money mo problems by rachel cruz it's
it's an absolute instant classic
but it's true i mean well explain keep
going further in that though i'm curious
what you mean by that
what the the the bigger the money oh so
bigger the paycheck the bigger the
problems bigger the debt bigger like if
you're not changing so i already have
behavior issue you were talking about i
was just reinforcing what you said which
is that if i don't have control of my
budget i don't have control of credit or
debit and all the junk that i'm spending
on and i get more money it doesn't fix
anything it just means i keep pouring
more fuel on an already existing fire
that's what i mean bigger paycheck
bigger problems now when we save when we
fix our behavior we save
after we've paid off debt we invest we
get our behavior in order then the
bigger paycheck now
bigger progress
that's the difference got to change your
behavior got to change that behavior
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
welcome back to the ramsey show i'm at
ramsay personality rachel cruz
in this hour with ken coleman ramsey
personality king coleman bestselling
author
and we are here to take your calls
america it's a free call anywhere in the
country at triple eight eight two five
five two two five so up next is scott
from houston texas hey scott welcome to
the show
hey good afternoon ken and rachel how
are you doing we're having a blast doing
great how can we help
good so i want to keep this brief
because i know other callers want to get
through too but rachel since this is an
opportunity to finally speak with you i
got to tell you your in-laws are awesome
people oh my goodness scott how do you
know buddy and helen
well that's i didn't know if we wanted
to name names or not oh but they claimed
me
well and his grandparents are awesome
too but wow yeah buddy senior so um
back when you and winston were in
college we were we went to church with
with buddy and helen okay yes and so his
his sister charlotte and her friends
used to babysit all of our kids oh my
gosh this was in high school small world
well i got to tell you that yeah and
they would always invite us they have
invited all the people with young
parents or young kids to come swim in
their pool so that's how we got to know
them over the years that i lived there
so who the heck news we don't scott
dropping from the wayback machine yeah
we don't always get the personal touch
here on the ramsay show i love that
scots well thanks for saying that yes
they are they are wonderful i am blessed
with really cool great in-laws so
that's awesome well how can we help
today
so the reason i was calling um
due to a recent divorce
i am trying to figure out
if i need to
kind of refresh the baby steps because
that had an impact not only on the
emergency fund and we had the sale of a
house
but it also impacted my
retirement savings
and so
i guess what i was trying to resolve is
one the proceeds from the house
should that be saved for the purchase of
the future house in a couple of years
or should that be
used to replenish the savings the
emergency savings we had and possibly
reconsider how to contribute to
retirement since that took a hit too
yeah
um so
um when was the divorce scott can i ask
yeah it was march and march okay it just
ended in march okay so everything is
final and
um correct assets are done yeah so you
so you know you have a good idea of what
you have versus what she has
um and so so the set when did the has
the house sold
the house sold in february okay yeah it
went really quickly um yeah and so scott
yeah do you have any debt you have no
debt still correct
correct okay and how much will you get
for
the sell of the house how much
so
what's left after we paid off things and
moved and all of that there's 40 000
left okay which came from
the sale of the house and then the
emergency fund that we had
went to pay all the miscellaneous
expenses
so that's been depleted too okay so you
have no emergency fund at all right
now correct and i've been waiting to
make a decision just to kind of let
things settle yeah um and then have the
chance to call in so what was your
emergency fund uh
together because now we're separate so
what what uh actually correct it's
irrelevant question i just answered my
own question let me ask it better uh
what is a three to six month emergency
fund for you right now
so
uh six months would be about thirty
thousand so you got that right now that
40 is yours right okay yeah and then you
have the 10 leftovers
yeah for sure so um yeah so i would do i
would i would put um 30 of that away
just as you're as that buffer emergency
find that fully funded emergency fund um
and then let's just see okay what what
are my next steps because if you want to
own a home again uh you know that's
coming up you can use that 10 grand
definitely for that if you know that
something you want to be doing soon here
in the future yeah i would put it
towards that
um but if there's not a
uh nothing on the horizon like you think
okay it's gonna be another year or two
before i buy or purchase then i would go
ahead and go to baby step four and start
funding retirement but i'm okay leaving
that 10 grand
uh just in a money market account or
something right now knowing that you're
gonna be purchasing purchasing a home in
the near future and just to kind of um
i don't know like be okay with right now
do you know what i'm saying scott like i
mean it's it's
very fresh i mean it was it just was
finalized in march and so
um taking some time and not make any big
knee-jerk reaction out of a big life
change like this i feel like is always
wise so i'm really sorry um that that
happened that's always that's always a
hard deal
well it is but we're i mean we're
handling it like adults and we're great
co-parents and so everything's going
well yeah
but yeah i just again it was okay is
that considered like your dad says found
money from the sale of the house or
should it be saved all for down payment
in the future so yes yeah yeah answer
the question though for sure yeah yeah
well it's a great question so yeah that
emergency fund go ahead and have that
that's a that's going to feel
have a level of stability for sure
financially and then keep that 10 grand
around for um and and continue to save
up down payments especially if you know
you're wanting to purchase something
soon so it's a great call
all right up next is elliott in chicago
hey elliot welcome to the show
hey how are you guys today doing great
how can we help
good so i got a question uh my wife and
i are expecting our first child in the
next couple weeks nice congratulations
yeah thank you thank you um we're
excited so getting getting things ready
here but uh so we've been working with
um some advisors that we have long term
relationships with regarding some
disability and life insurance and just
wanted to call and get um your all's
opinion on you know if there's kind of a
standard formula that you look at or you
know how much is too much and what what
do we really need
in order to be safe moving forward yeah
that's great for life insurance
specifically correct
yeah yeah i think i think you know we we
both have a couple policies in place and
and we're being advised to up that a
little bit more and not sure if we
should go with you know whole life or
supplement with term um so those are the
questions i have yeah great question so
term 100 i would not do whole life
insurance because what whole life
insurance is is you get a policy uh
that's very expensive and then they take
some of that money and they it's cash
value quote unquote so then they go and
put it in basically an investment a
terrible savings account with a really
low rate of return so the rule of thumb
i always use elliott is you never want
your insurance
and your investments to be together they
should always be separate so by having
just term life insurance it's so
inexpensive we use xander insurance my
husband and i do and they're amazing
just go to xander.com you literally put
in your information they will shop all
of the top policies around from all
different companies and get you the best
policy so it's really inexpensive my
husband i actually we just we just did
ours um again just i think it was last
year and i still was shocked by how
inexpensive which granted we're younger
and
and healthy and all of that i did it too
a couple years ago and uh i lost weight
like a wrestler and got the preferred
rate oh monkey you can really do it you
can do it you can get a good rate if
you're healthy but it's inexpensive it's
crazy so what's your life and then i
would say to scott i'm sorry elliott
real quick um you want to get 10 to 12
times your annual income
and your wife even if she's gonna stay
home with the baby so if she's working
then again 10 to 12 times her her income
but if she's home i would get about a
half a million dollar policy on her uh
even if she's a stay-at-home mom so yeah
you both will want term life insurance
and it's a great move i'm so glad that
you guys are looking at this because
it's um
it's real it's really important
especially now you've got a little baby
coming yeah and you're giving the
financial advice but i don't want to
miss this no cheeseburgers no quarter
pounders for a good week it's gotta
really get lean before the blood test
i'm telling you folks this is somebody's
got to tell you save your money actually
i will say
cholesterol for dudes is based on that
junk food you eat i'm telling you and if
you smoke cigars or drink alcohol don't
do any of that either because i didn't
know somebody and they got the results
back and everything was crazy and
they're like what
and no one told them not to have a glass
of wine or something like that
i am a man of the people i'm telling you
guys
watch the diet lose some weight by the
way your wife will be thrilled with that
it's like it's like multiple benefits
there you get it all so elliot again
term life insurance and the 12 times
your income and
don't eat that burger the night before
yeah no quarterback that was uh for old
king coleman yeah ken thanks for hosting
today great being with you always fun i
want to thank everyone in the booth
kelly james ben zach andrew everyone
back there
thanks again america for listening this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey folks ken coleman here did you know
the ramsay show is one of the most
popular podcasts in the world it's your
daily dose of advice on life and money
check out all of our shows from the
ramsey network wherever you listen to
podcasts
[Music]
this is the ramsay show
you can be intentional about your
character you can have money and a
career you are the hero in your story
[Music]
live from the headquarters of ramsey
solutions this is the ramsay show where
america hangs out to have a conversation
about your life and your money i am
ramsey personality rachel cruz hosting
this hour along with i guess our newest
yeah ramsay personality christina ellis
yay so happy to be here oh it's like
it's like the two women we're taking
over y'all for the hour and it's so
great and we even thought like it'd be
fun to have we have some men on hold so
we will definitely we will definitely
take
calls if you are a man but it would be
fun to do one segment of just women so
ladies give us a call and we will chat
about life and money but also america
it's a free call to anyone
out there at
eight two five five two two five so
we'll talk about your money we can talk
about your career your life your
relationships anything and everything so
give us a call all right first up we
have matt from huntsville hey matt
welcome to the show all right thank you
absolutely how can we help
i i'm um i'm a
one of the wave of resignees uh
recently i'm just i'm coming back to the
workforce after 11 years i mean after 11
months okay yeah yeah it was nice to
take a little breather there
but now that i'm back
one of the things i'm i'm doing is is
electing my investments and my company
matches
and i get to choose
whether it's a traditional 401 or a roth
401
and i'm wondering if one makes sense
over the other or should it be a blend
no the raw we always will gear towards
the roth because it will grow tax-free
you'll you'll use um after-tax dollars
to invest in
so that's kind of the only kicker but
it's so worth it because you would
rather
pay with that money even though you've
paid taxes on it your take-home pay
basically into that roth and so that way
it grows for the rest of the time
completely tax-free what do you what do
you do for a living matt
i'm an engineer an engineer okay that's
awesome so great uh do you have anything
saved in any other retirement or is this
kind of the first one you're tapping
into oh no i've got some others it's
lately i've been uh holding it in cash
and it's kind of embarrassing to say
right now but it's just the truth um
i had pulled out of the market at one
point and um
so yeah but the thing that i was
wondering about is is when it comes to
tax uh rates
when i am retired would i not be
um i mean i imagine i'm going to have a
lower income so i didn't know if that
would put me in a lower bracket and
that's kind of the reason for that
question that i had yeah you could but i
think the amount of time how old are you
55 55 okay yeah well i mean the growth
over that amount of time because even if
you because i guess in an ideal world
too if you're not taking it all
completely out some of that is still
going to be growing so the growth and
the compounding interest will be going
you know hopefully for for a while so um
so no i would still always choose that
roth again it's kind of that tax
sheltered plan and it is going to help
over the long term and so that's what i
would but i also met i would sit down
with a smartvestor pro you can find
those at ramseysolutions.com but but
interview two three of them um but i
would i would sit down with an
investment professional because i know
you mentioned you got out of the market
and probably out of maybe some fear i
don't know why um but i think it is wise
to say hey at your age what can i be
doing to be making more money that's
smart and wise nothing too risky or
crazy um but at least gives you enough
for enough padding so
um i think that that's probably the best
bet matt so thanks for calling and
that's great that his company offers
that because a lot yeah don't and that
was one of the things i was most excited
about coming here to ramsey is that we
have the roth 401k it's got so many
benefits long term so if your company
has that that is definitely something
awesome to look into absolutely and then
even when you look at you know just iras
the roth ira is even the better way to
go than the traditional iras so again
that roth protects all of the growth uh
and it'll be tax-free which is just
wonderful
all right up next is jeff from aspen
hey jeff i have so many dumb and dumber
jokes in my head but i'm not gonna say
them
hey guys how's it going good how are you
good thanks hey i've got a lot of
details i'll try and sum it all up
quickly okay
my fiance and i are getting married here
in about a month and a half
congratulations just doing a lot of
future planning thank you
and she is finishing up her bachelor's
degree next month and is doing her
master's at the same time so she'll be a
year in on her master's upon graduating
with her bachelor's
um she's moving here to aspen with me
and we're trying to figure out how to
continue her masters
while also battling our hundred thousand
dollars in the student loan debt
um i've got three potential routes
one of which is for her to
stay here and if she gets a job with the
city the city can potentially help pay
for it like five thousand a year
uh the other option issue doesn't work
for the city is for us to just postpone
masters and try and knock out debt as
fast as possible
um and the third option is there's a
program through a church that's
connected with the school that she went
to for her undergrad
that will pay for her master's but we
have to move to nebraska
and potentially live with hosts and i'd
have to change jobs that kind of thing
so yeah none of them are
anything we're leaning towards it's just
a matter of which one do we take yes
whatever the the wisest do you guys have
the money right now for her to go
complete her masters or will you guys be
taking on more debt for that
well we're not planning on taking out
loans so if anything would be cash
flowing yet um her grandparents have
offered to pay for about nine thousand
dollars towards that school
um so that's helpful but that's only a
portion of it how much is a year in
right now and how much is the total well
well you got after you guys get married
what all will you guys have to pay for
her masters what amount
i'm thinking it's somewhere in the 20 to
25 000 range okay and how long it's like
5 000 a semester okay and how much will
you guys be making a year
i make 53 right now and and her moving
here it could be anywhere between you
know 40 and 55 probably something like
that okay we'll be close to 100 i
anticipate close to 100 okay
so christina you you're the master at
this because she she got her masters
completely paid for with scholarships
and grants which is amazing yeah i love
that you've already explored so many
options like the fact that you called in
and have boom boom boom three different
options that you've already explored i
just love that because a lot of people
they get really focused on one route or
they think the only way student loans
and they just don't explore options but
when you really start digging in and
looking deep there are so many different
options available so i want you all to
go the next step the next level and
start looking at more options so
scholarships i won over a half million
dollars in scholarships and was able to
get my bachelor's and master's debt free
it takes some digging but they are out
there there's fellowships for master's
programs so see what's available there
some schools are even tuition free so i
don't know exactly what program she
wants but if you keep exploring you
might be able to find one that's either
tuition free or a much reduced cost even
if she goes online maybe that's an
option maybe she can even work for a
college maybe if she works for a local
university she can get a decent percent
off so just keep leaning into that
exploration of options you're already
doing it but take it a step further
because there's a lot of choices out
there yes that's such good advice
because you guys are gonna be making i
mean you're making six figures if all
your
math if all you know what you said was
correct and you guys have a 100 000 in
debt so i'm like she could go to school
possibly even completely paid for
whether it's through scholarships or
grants or a combination of some online
uh if there's an option there that's
more less expensive or working for the
university everything that christina
just laid out i'm like if you can bundle
a bunch of that stuff together and get
her masters where you're not paying
completely just out of pockets then you
guys can be attacking the student loans
as well to get that paid off but i again
do not do the masters if you're going to
be taking debt on at all no no no and
get it as down as possible by these
other options so that you can work on
paying off the undergrad
this is the ramsay show
[Music]
life is full of firsts
[Music]
as the first and longest serving
christian health cost sharing ministry
chm has shared medical expenses for its
members since 1981.
we believe you should have the freedom
to focus on your health while being
supported by a community of believers
giving you the opportunity to create
many more firsts
[Music]
well one of the main reasons christina
joined our personality team i want to
say the main i guess the man said we
love you the second reason would be
uh because your story is incredible
about getting half a million dollars to
go to school debt-free you even went to
vanderbilt university which is so
expensive um and you just are a living
testimony and have such a passion for
this subject because it is such a huge
one
and that's one of your passions one
thing that you love and that you're able
to talk to so much here at ramsey
solutions yeah i'm so passionate about
it there are so many students who feel
like student loans are the only way to
go
i'm talking to so many of my friends who
are drowning in student loan debt and i
just want people to see that there is
another way you do not have to take on
debt to go to college so we are doing a
college theme hour next week next
thursday where you can ask your
questions around saving for college
paying for college scholarships and
going to college debt-free so go to
ramseysolutions.com
ask and put college and the subject line
i cannot wait to chat with everyone
about this
full hour just on college which is huge
because there's so much news around it
whether it's forgiveness or forbearance
they're pausing alone i mean it's just
it's crazy so
the idea to have a starting point of not
even thinking about loans or taking on
loans uh when you are in high school and
that you get to launch forward into
college without it is just huge but you
have to have a plan so christina's here
to help yeah let us help you figure out
how to find that freedom as you go to
college you can feel empowered and pay
for it yes without debt yes
speaking of the young people so uh
the old gen z i want to just stereotype
them for a second
but there was a hashtag that gained over
360 million views
on social media but specifically with
tick tock and the hashtag was called
cash stuffing
so these young people have realized
oh my gosh
i can actually get real cash
and put them in envelopes
and label the envelopes what i'm going
to spend the money on
and then when i go to spend the money i
take the envelope with me and i take the
cash out
and when there's no more cash in the
envelope i stop spending and they they
they are on to something christina no
way this has never been done in the
history of humanity
but man i mean uh 360 million views
on this topic and they're calling it
cash stuffing so
they're they're just they they're coming
up with new stuff all the time
like y'all it reminds me of like fashion
trends whenever it's like our generation
is doing it right
for us it's high-waisted jeans but for
everyone else's mom jeans that's a 100
100 so now they have they have
found the uh solution of using cash
which ah the rachel cruise wallet does
the same thing too because here at
ramsey we've been teaching this for like
30 some years
because there is a power in it there
really is uh
spending your money so cash 100 you feel
it your debit card you do feel it to an
extent because you know it's money
coming right out of your account
but when you're using other forms of
payment whether it's loans credit cards
all of it there's just this level of
you're just detached because it's not
your money you're spending so you're
technically and and studies show you do
spend more so
i'm joking about gen z kind of making
fun of them but i love it you guys i
love the cash stuffing i'm so glad this
is becoming cool again
this is brilliant maybe we're like
making like a full circle because
there's other we won't get into this
this show maybe next week about the
microchip and all i mean like like
there's some ends going crazy but then
they're coming back
they're coming back to the old school
ways of cash and i love it i love it you
know as long as they get there
that's right even if it's got a new coat
of paint like they're getting there and
that's great absolutely absolutely well
christina and i are taking your calls so
it's a free call anywhere in the country
triple eight eight two five five two two
five so up next is
laura from ontario hey laura welcome to
the show
hi hi welcome welcome how can we help
thank you okay so
i am newly married
and uh we're both remarried
and i have my house and he has his house
well there they're hours because we're
married but
um i'm gonna sell my house okay and i'm
really proud of my house and i
i bought it by myself and
to sell it is a bit sad
so i was thinking if i could take the
money and use it to buy a condo
rent the condo out for 15 years until
we're ready to retire or ready to
downsize at the end there
and i know like the ramsey idea is to
um basically just
not put the money into another loan but
put the money into
his house
his mortgage
but i'm just thinking since i i'm so
attached to my house if i could then
just transfer it into
a condo okay
so there's a couple of things i just
kind of want to ask you about because
even some of your phrasing a little bit
is still you know his mortgage my you
know it still is this well just for
simplicity's sake because we instead of
saying like the house at this address in
the house with that address sure sure
but you guys are bo are you both selling
the homes and buying something new are
you moving into his home his current
home
we're moving into his house his house
okay okay no that's fair i hear you i
hear you i know it's just kind of
semantics i just want to i just want to
double double check that
um the way you're viewing it so what
about this first house
um are you so attached to because you
said i i'm so proud of it which yes you
should be i mean that's that's amazing
um but was there was there kind of a
story behind it that that makes it more
sentimental
yes it's pretty sentimental yes yeah
yeah what's causing you guys to
not move into that one i'm just curious
and sell his house is uh his house is a
much better location okay
uh it's on the water it's closer to all
the kids sure sure okay and what what's
sentimental about your current house
part of me what what is sentimental what
are those emotional ties that you still
have to your current house
well like there's the pride that i
bought it myself
on my own and i raised my kids here yeah
yes
i mean that's
that's hard why we um
we moved out of the house that all three
were born in uh two years ago and it was
i mean there's an emotional pull to a
mom's heart that you're like this was
the place that our kids were raised um
and then also to your point that you did
this on your own and there is a level to
celebrate that and i think that that's
that's incredible laura but i would also
say too that um
taking those things that you are so
proud of
and having that same level of dignity
and honor
putting that um forward
into you and your husband's life and
your marriage now and what it is
um really can take you far i think
there's a level of grieving of saying
man i've moved past this stage of life
and i'm in a different i'm in a
different stage
but i think you can still honor yourself
and be proud um without feeling like you
have to just go buy another condo to
continue feeling that way i think you
can still
get that feeling of dignity
elsewhere yeah i think that grieving
process is so important we're actually
in a similar situation where we actually
close on our old house on tuesday and
i'm going through the emotions of this
is where we brought our babies home we
love this house and like i had to take a
full night and just have a good cry in
the living room and grieve it and i feel
like going through that we've been able
to make a lot better financial decisions
moving forward so i don't know if you've
done it yet but i would encourage you to
take that time to just grieve that house
say goodbye i feel like i'm channeling
my inner john bologna
but like take that time but it's real
yes so so on the tactical side though
laura i i would not just rush in and buy
something else because i feel like
that's going to be kind of a band-aid on
getting a feeling that you need met
where i really think you can get that
level of dignity some in another way
that's even financially wise so
um do you guys have any consumer debt or
is it just the house payment the
mortgage on his that he'll have
just the mortgage just the mortgage okay
so how much would you get for the sell
of your home your current home
well because the market is so strange
right now i i'm not sure um
at the end of when the gusts are settled
it'll be between one and two hundred
thousand okay and how much does he owe
on his
300 300 okay
so i think what could be
um
what i think would be cool and i really
would suggest this is that you guys have
a goal together
that you guys want to have and so i
would if i were you laura i would put
that money into the mortgage um i'd go
ahead and just work on paying that off
but then you guys together have a goal
and say hey as a married couple now that
we are one what is something we want is
it a condo that we want to invest in and
after our mortgage is paid off we're
going to go after that you know what
what is something that we want to do as
a couple together and there is a unity
that is
created in that for you guys that i
think it could be so beautiful but i we
both hear you and understands that it
can be hard to let go of things
especially when you do it on your own
and it feels so good but i really would
channel that towards your marriage this
is the ramsay show
[Music]
[Music]
standing on the debt free stage here at
ramsey solutions headquarters is ted and
tabby
and you guys are standing there for a
reason so welcome thank you thank you so
much and you are here to do your debt
free screen yes oh so exciting you guys
congratulations thank you so where are
you guys from
toledo ohio yep okay so great and how
much have you paid off
59 000. amazing and what kind of debt
was it
rachel and christina it um we finished
off the house got entrusted to us oh my
gosh your mortgage and everything
everything you're completely debt-free
oh my gosh look at this baby step seven
yeah amazing so was it the mo so it was
the mortgage that last 59 000 yeah
completely paid off the house you guys
and how long did that take you
23 months well the last
yeah the last little bit took 23 months
23 months okay and how much were you
guys making during that time
84 to 92 84 to 92 000. all right and
what do you guys do for a living
i am an independent consultant with a
beauty company but i also have a side
hustle of making pumpkin rolls and
selling them like at thanksgiving time
oh that's awesome very cool very very
cool and ted what do you do i'm a
chemical engineer but i like to say i'm
a missionary at a glass manufacturing
plant oh there you go that's awesome
that's awesome well you guys so the
mortgage everything is paid off so what
happened 23 months ago to get this boss
started well there's a story behind that
there was a pivot point okay and we
actually so we went through fpu when we
got married eight years ago
um part of our premarital counseling and
the first five years that we were in the
house
we did the most genuine form of
ramsay-ish
so we
we were taking advantage we were doing
everything but we were going to take
advantage of the american express and
the discover cash back so we had our
envelopes we put our groceries our
restaurants
and our gas in envelopes and then we
would use the credit card we would come
home and this is the idea
to use the take the receipt and the cash
from the envelope and put it in a box
and then it was gone right
it doesn't work oh
i was like okay
so it sounds so good because why not
just get free money but um
so we did that for the first five years
and then i was driving home i have this
rhythm of listening to proverbs on the
way to work and then
listening to the ramsey show on the way
home to keep me awake
and i was on hill and holland sylvania
coming up to this light and i heard
chris hogan say to someone who was a
hundred thousand in debt and here we
were you know no consumer debt and
telling them telling this lady to cut up
all her credit cards
and i was like man we're not even in
debt why
if he's telling her to cut him up we
should try this so we we decided to do a
study on ourselves and we went two
months
of using just cash and debit card yeah
and um
we saved
just as much money in one month and we
did it like two months in a row
in one month as we did
at the end of the year getting our cash
back from american express so we were
working wow
300 back at the end of the year and we
did that two months in a row just by not
spending it and it was so frustrating
because i love it
free money i know okay so why didn't it
work because i mean we have our rants
here behind the glass that we say almost
every day so for you guys did it though
so so why didn't it work so talk to the
people that are just like you guys that
are like oh yeah we're fine we're fine
we're fine why didn't it work for you to
do the whole oh we can pay it off and
cash back and all that i think because
especially like gas that's a big thing
that people like just use it for gas
but we found that when we got to like
the end of our gas we were like okay
we're not going to drive as much or
we're going to go on a date that's
closer than where we thought or you're
more conscious about when you're
spending your money
um and then it was like oh well someone
invited us to go do something we don't
want to say no
and so it's just those little like slip
ups or you forget about something
and it's not in the budget and those
little things just really add up they do
oh you guys that's amazing so i love
that you're kind of the ish you cut it
up and then you started attacking the
mortgage and so what did that journey
look like for you guys well just real
quick so yeah we only paid off 28 000 on
the mortgage those first five years
and the last 59 was in 23 months like it
just wow it just it was amazing how it
picked up but i forget your question
that's amazing
uh i don't even remember what i think i
just like about the journey yeah the
journey to after you guys decide to cut
out the credit cards and you're like
we're gonna really go full force on the
mortgage
what were the things that happened like
what did you guys do to help that really
propel forward because you said you
really kicked it into gear even the last
23 months well we started using every
dollar which i don't i don't know if it
was new at the time or we just weren't
familiar with it and it took him a
couple months to get me on board with it
because
i don't like change tabby there's this
way that we can both have it on our
phones we can both always know what's
left and so
yeah every dollar was what yeah helped
there so then we also had like a chart
that ted made he's all about the excel
spreadsheets and so it has a picture of
our house in the background um and that
it also has like um a space for each
thousand that we paid off so each time
we got to a thousand we would like cross
it off with our highlighter um and so
sometimes you'd be like we get to do two
this month so i would run over and i
would
color them in and stuff and the kids
were getting excited about watching it
as well so for sure um the more blocks
you color off the more you get excited
as it gets to the end the amortization
schedule was awesome that was our friend
so good i love y'all's motivation and
your excitement
you are extremely self-motivated but of
course there's probably people who are
in your community cheering you on who
are your biggest cheerleaders
yeah so definitely paul and michelle
beech they were our fpu coordinators um
when we first took the class before we
got married um they've been the biggest
but we have a lot of people that are
excited for us for sure did you have
anyone that thought you guys were crazy
for even cutting up the credit cards and
trying to pay off your mortgage were
they like you're nuts not that people
said but you can tell like when when you
tell them they're like okay
but they didn't say anything yes okay
and you how old are you guys 30 and 31.
oh my gosh with a paid off house that's
incredible what would you tell all of
our younger generation you know our age
group who thinks this can't happen
there's no way i could live debt-free
with no mortgage what would you tell
those people
you can and i think one of the most fun
parts is like being on a team like we're
both going towards the same goal and so
each time we would cross off one of
those boxes it was like we were both
excited um because we both just wanted
that goal so much and so being on the
same team i think is is the biggest
asset oh absolutely and you guys are
such a picture of that yeah there's i
mean there's so many couples you talk to
that you know he does all the finances
or she does all the finances and the
other one like gets permission and when
you're on the same team you help each
other out and it's just
that part's amazing and the other thing
is just realizing like it's all god's
like it's not 10 is his and 90 like we
are here to manage what he's entrusted
to us like matthew 25 and the parable of
the talents like
god what do you want us to do with this
and um it's beautiful it's awesome you
guys oh and you guys have three little
ones right and you're expecting number
four right what are you doing june 20th
okay it's coming up okay do you are you
gonna bring the little ones in for the
yes they're coming they've been
practicing perfect perfect they're
coming from the table i may have jumped
them too much that they have all their
crayons and everything they're so cute
okay and what are their names and ages
all right so we have brinley she's six
jana is four and ethan is two oh my
goodness you guys have your hands full
but in the midst of all of that
completely paid off your mortgage you
guys absolutely feel
it's amazing like we want everyone to
have this feeling yeah
yeah like um just the options that you
have now like now
however much money per month does not
have to go to that like it's right one
month it can be this one month it can be
this so it's like god what do you want
to do next i love it i love it well you
guys we're gonna give you a copy of the
baby steps uh millionaire's book because
that's the next uh chapter of your story
and total money makeover for you to give
away to another couple like you guys to
help them on this so we have ted and
tabby from toledo ohio paying off 59
dollars in 23 months making 84 to 92 000
their house and everything
count it down let's hear a debt-free
scream all right you ready
three two one
[Music]
amazing
oh my gosh
oh christina
my heart is always so full but number
one when anyone does this it changes
their life but you see these little ones
and i'm like and they're never going to
know the difference they're always going
to see the way to handle your money and
be in control because of their parents
and i think it's just beautiful changing
their family tree right there mortgage
and everything right what a legacy to
leave that's incredible and now they
have so much life ahead of them to save
and give and
[Music]
rock stars so good this is the ramsay
show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
so
[Music]
speak up for those who cannot speak for
themselves for the rights of all who are
desolate destitute
speak up and judge fairly
defend the rights of the poor in the
needy proverbs 31
8 through 9.
yeah yeah i quoted proverbs i'm probably
gonna get like struck down
character actually i love this quote
character i mean i love proverbs too but
this one's great too character cannot be
developed in the ease and the quiet only
through experience of trial and
suffering can the soul be strengthened
ambition inspired and success achieved
helen keller that's beautiful wow i do
love that because i think there is
and and i feel like we're seeing it more
and more but
you know we live in such a world that
it's like everyone just wants
whatever they want when they want it
including becoming debt-free right like
when we talk to people about getting out
of debt it's like oh no i have
six-figure student loans like the amount
seems impossible
um it's not worth the sacrifice it's not
worth doing all like it's just worth
keeping around right like that's kind of
one mindset people can have
where i'm like yeah but
or if they want it paid off like i want
to just paid off in two months like i
wish i could just pay it off in two
months and of course that would be
amazing but there's something about even
the journey of becoming debt free
through that process there's like a
refining
that happens
in your soul and in your heart when you
go through sacrifice that you just don't
get at the mountaintop and there's
blessings and i think that that is
wonderful um to have those in your life
but there is something about walking a
journey
uh that's not always easy that creates
something the character in you yeah
that's so good and i think we're seeing
kind of the flip side of that with the
younger generation and some of their
thoughts on investing it's like how can
we get there quickly can we do crypto
can we do these get cr
get rich quick yes
it's like you know it takes time but the
journey it's worth it you know reading
baby steps millionaires it's like oh you
see all these stories and it's so
inspiring it takes time it takes work it
takes effort but you can get there and
it's just such an amazing journey yeah
and the journey through it is what
refines who you are and i think it's
it's awesome so
all right we're gonna go to james in new
york hey james welcome to the show
hi thank you for taking my call
absolutely welcome how can we help
uh my wife and i are our new listeners
um
we had a question so we've been living
with my in-laws for the past three and a
half years uh trying to save up for a
house
um
uh but
we also have a little bit of debt that
we've been working on uh we knocked down
about fifteen thousand credit cards um
my wife has uh uh some student loans and
then uh we both have car payments we
don't we're not sure if we should use
what we have saved
towards buying a house uh to
take care of the rest of that debt
and then just start over
um you know saving up for for a down
payment again yep yeah it's a great
question how much do you own your
student loans
uh is there's uh
30 000 student loans total okay and how
about the cars
27 000. is that just within one car is
that two combined
that's one car the other car is a lease
that uh i'm going to that's my which is
my car uh that's the i'm gonna
get out of okay okay
and how much do you guys make a year
uh together uh
200 000 um before taxes okay and how
much is in that savings that y'all were
saving for a house
uh it's sixty thousand sixty thousand
okay
um so james i think one way we answer
calls on the show is if we woke up in
your shoes tomorrow
what would i what would i do in your
situation so um
the in-law situation is it you guys have
been there a while three and a half
years are you all
i mean do you have kids are y'all ready
to get out are you i mean that's kind of
a long time
yeah it's longer than i thought it was
going to be we we also we we just had
our our second child uh a couple months
ago and she's four months old
congratulations
thank you um but yeah it's getting a
little crowded and uh yeah
we we thought we would have um
be able to move out by this point but uh
the with house prices being the way they
are
we put a couple of offers in and and we
get outbid by
you know where we're already offering
over 50 thousand we get up and outfit by
another fifties
totally yeah it's it's crazy right now
so yeah so yeah james if i were you guys
and i woke up i would take that 60 and i
would just be debt-free i would just pay
off the car i would pay off the student
loan tomorrow like i would i would just
be out of debt uh and then i would be
and then i would really aggressively
save because you guys make an incredible
income
um so i would save really aggressively
to get a fully funded emergency fund of
three to six months of expenses
to get that saved and then at the same
time i would look to rent somewhere
which i know is not ideal and people are
like oh man i hate renting especially
when you had a house
envisioned and you guys were working
towards home ownership um but listen i i
would i think that there's something
that happens when you're on your own uh
even though the idea of being home
you're saving money and like there's
some really good intentions around it
um sometimes it can kind of get not that
you're being lazy by any means but it's
almost like you have the safety net
under you of the in-laws house
that you might make different decisions
and even more aggressive decisions when
it's just you and your wife and you guys
are having to just do it on your own so
i would move out and look just to rent
somewhere even for a year a year or two
and then say okay let's get that fully
funded emergency fund and then let's
start working i would then press play to
save up for a down payment and by then
to james i mean that's going to be
probably in the next two years
which i know is a length or a longer
time for you guys of wanting to be in a
house i totally understand that but
also it gives time for the market to
like
kind of settle on what's happening right
now you know what i'm saying like you
would be buying at the top and if you
guys had the money to do it you could
um but you guys don't have i don't think
you have the money for it because you
guys still have a lot of debt you don't
have savings for an emergency fund and i
think you're just going to set yourself
up for a lot of stress so
if i were you and i woke up in your
shoes i would pay off the debt tomorrow
start aggressively getting that
emergency fund in place while looking
for somewhere to rent for the next two
two three years yeah that's great and
especially with such a great income they
can do that quickly that's right like
they can go into it with peace and
confidence and having that really great
down payment and be completely debt-free
so i think they'll get there pretty
quick yes absolutely
all right next is david from
new york we got two new york calls here
david welcome to the show
all right check check can y'all hear me
yeah we can hear you david how can we
help you're the last call on friday
oh that's beautiful that's beautiful
life is good um
so i hope y'all doing well i just had a
very um
well to me it's an interesting question
y'all probably get this all the time but
me and my lady was sitting down last
night
my beautiful wife
and i'm very grateful because
we are 99.9 percent
aligned nice
on the entire budget amazing okay what's
the point one percent
her position is as follows okay well
um
i feel
that there should be a line item in the
budget
for personal expenditures because if i
want to go get my nails done i should be
able to do that and i said baby listen
my position is as follows there's gonna
be a time
when you can get your nails done every
other day
you can get your hair done every week
for now
we gotta eliminate the personal
expenditures entirely stick to the plan
and aggressively build up
this emergency fund
so my question is whoa she being a
princess
am i being too rigid or is there some
kind of compromise
okay well i need to know first david are
you guys when you say you're working for
your emergency fund so are you out of
debt and you're working for your fully
funded emergency fund
that's correct okay awesome well
congratulations uh thank you i'm i'm
gonna go i
i'm i'm gonna be in the middle here
i'm gonna be in the middle investing a
lot of money either okay so david i'm
i'm
i'm gonna be a little bit on her side
because here's what we have found even
if it's like even if it's not a lot of
money just something small something
small because it's realistic and that's
what the budget is supposed to reflect
yes it's supposed to reflect sacrifice
to get
that emergency fund funded as quickly as
possible so i'm with you on that like i
hear that intensity and it's like yes um
but you also want to be realistic so
does she need to go and get her nails
done
every week no she doesn't so but can she
treat herself to something small
um once a month that has a little bit of
money in there and again it may not be
what she wants because you guys are kind
of you are still in that season of
sacrifice but it at least gives a a
little bit of that of that breathing
room and motivation to be like okay i
kind of get my you know that scratch
itch somewhere uh else other than
feeling like i'm going 300 dollars into
like the beauty section of life of hair
and nails and stuff until that emergency
fund was funded that's it but it's a
great question dave but it's when a lot
of people have so great and i love that
even though we mostly had guy callers we
still got to talk about it we didn't we
did we did well thanks thank kelly james
ben zack and andrew in the booth thank
you america for calling in and chatting
christina so fun hosting with you
and this is the ramsay show
[Music]
hey it's rachel cruz co-host on the
ramsay show if you want to do your
debt-free stream live on the show visit
debt free ramseysolutions.com we'd love
for you to come to nashville and tell
dave your story that's ramsey
solutions.com
debt free screen
[Music]
you